what we're trying ready Wow I gotta
finish apartment hunting stuff because
apartment honey sucks dude especially
because it sucks family's is up and
they're going up on your answer as much
as I don't want to oh yeah I'm out man
well baby there's always room you have
tons of room in that my house yeah I
hear a bunch of screaming everyday
negative Hey you're like way too quick
with it okay you stay the night there at
1:00 what's for tonight dude you're not
moving in and no that's way too quick
but you recognize this moment but s
pumping grace slowed it down I mean I
appreciate but that's wait wait wait I
just met the kids dude enjoy all right
moving in no I mean I appreciate that
we're gonna do but I need an apartment
seriously so can I come stay at your
house or what's wrong you can come visit
you can't stay stay if you look up
condition F information of the word
state Geno's right for the last two
years this has been me and Alana and
pumpkin the last man that we lived with
with sugar bear and we're still getting
over that disaster the more I think
about it we're not ready for no man in
the movie and plus it's about to get
real crowd and they were pumpkins baby
on the way
I mean look although every kind of
father I need to go oh look we're here
on date let's please all of you
[Music]